hallo zusammen heute gibt es Teil 2 von
euren Fragen generell zum Thema backen
und kochen wir decken die fails auf
warum etwas schief läuft was man da
besser machen kann die Fragen kamen alle
über Instagram rein und falls ihr
weitere Fragen habt dann immer unten in
die Kommentare schreiben
mein Lieblingsthema Biskuitböden
Standard viskuitboden ist nie so hoch
wie bei dir trotz langsam unterheben
hier wird das Ergebnis von der Bäckerin
verglichen mit dem was dem Video zu
sehen ist also es kommt drauf an mir ist
aufgefallen wenn ich mal in meinem Video
mein Handrührgerät benutze sind die Eier
ganz anders fluffig als wenn ich die
Küchenmaschine nehme ich predige immer
ihr braucht nicht die teuersten Geräte
um backen zu können aber es bringt euch
schon auf ein anderes Level das ist
einfach Fakt und wenn ich das mit der
Küchenmaschine mit ganz viel Geduld
einfach schlagen lasse dann wird der
auch hoch und wenn man dann beim
unterheben dann müsst ihr auch immer
aufpassen beim unterheben man trennt der
Eiweiß von Eigelb beim Biskuitboden da
auch nicht mit zu schnellen Bewegungen
weil dann schlagt ihr die Luft raus und
dann immer schön langsam manchmal habe
ich auch richtig Armschmerzen und kriegt
voll den Tennisarm aber ich mache dann
richtig mit Geduld damit einfach so
wenig Luftbläschen wie wie
nötig damit einfach wenig Luftbläschen
entweichen so das ist ganz ganz wichtig
kann man für einen Biskuitboden auch
Dinkelmehl verwenden ja Dinkelmehl Typ
630 lässt sich immer mit diesem
standardmehl Typ 405 ersetzen das ist
kein Problem andere Typen das hat wieder
andere klebeigenschaften da müsstet ihr
wieder das Rezept anpassen aber merkt
euch Typ 630 könnt ihr immer ersetzen
die Ränder vom Biskuitboden bleiben
manchmal noch krümelig nach dem Backen
direkt nach dem Backen ist das auch
normal weil von außen die Ränder
bekommen ja immer die meiste Hitze ab
das ist also ganz normal aber wenn ihr
euren Biskuitboden wenn ihr Zeit habt
und ihr könnt den ersten paar Stunden
später oder am nächsten Tag verarbeiten
wickelt ihn einfach in Frischhaltefolie
gib den in den Kühlschrank und dann ist
dann nichts mehr an Krümeln da am
nächsten Tag Biskuitboden sagt nach dem
Backen in der Mitte ein was mache ich
falsch
das habe ich sehr oft schon gelesen
warum sagt mein Biskuitboden ein dazu
muss ich immer sagen also auf Instagram
habe ich einmal diesen Austausch dass
man hin und her schreiben kann und ich
frage mal hey welches Rezept nimmst du
denn nimmst du eins von mir oder eine
anderes und oft nehmen die Leute halt
nicht meinen Rezept mir ist es damals
hat man mit mit 14 ungefähr angefangen
zu backen mir ist es damals mit
fremdrezepten auch immer passiert dass
der wirklich in der Mitte ein sagt wie
so eine Kohle und dann schneidet man den
durch und der dritte Boden ist
eigentlich nichts mehr das sind nur noch
so außenfetzen und da habe ich mir dann
überlegt ich entwickle jetzt mein
eigenes biskuitbodenrezept und es steht
schon seit ich glaube ich 17 oder 18 bin
und das habe ich euch auch auf meinem
YouTube-Kanal hinterlegt und macht das
probiert es mal nach meinem Rezept aus
das wird euch nicht mehr passieren ich
habe es halt wirklich perfektioniert und
bin da auch sehr sehr stolz drauf hast
doch ganz lustig ist einmal habe ich
unter einem Video gesehen wo halt auch
mein Rezept benutzt wurde man erkennt
halt so ein Rezept weil das nicht eins
zu eins genommen die grammangaben äh das
da geschrieben wurde ihr die Community
erkennt aber auch immer das ist mein
Rezept ist und schreibt da drunter
einfach das Rezept von Kiki und dann hat
die videoerstellerin noch tatsächlich
geschrieben nee nee Tiki kopiert das
doch auch von irgendwo jeder nimmt das
immer von irgendwo und das ist einfach
nicht so es ist wirklich selbst
entwickelt und ich entwickle alle meine
Rezepte auf meinem Kanal selbst und sie
sind doch alle gelingen sicher daher
gerne mal in dem Video vorbeischauen ich
hinterlasst euch da mal Link in der
Infobox bei mir wird der Schokobiskuit
nach der Zugabe der trockenen Zutaten
etwas fest und klumpig und nicht fluffig
okay das kann daran liegen dass die
trockenen Zutaten alle auf einmal dazu
gegeben werden weil beim biscuit ist ja
so dass die also die das Eiweiß vom
Eigelb getrennt wird und irgendwann
verbindet man es ja wieder und dann hat
man eine ultra fluffige Masse und da
dann mit dem Sieb die ganzen trockenen
Zutaten drauf zu hauen ist ja fatal
deshalb muss man immer in zwei drei
Schritten arbeiten also man ein bisschen
was dazu sieben und darin dann wieder
ein bisschen was es ist halt immer das
Resultat von Ungeduld wenn etwas
irgendwie nicht wird daher immer schön
in in mehreren Schritten rein oder
unterheben und dazu geben anstatt alles
auf einmal dazu zu geben wichtig ist es
da natürlich gerade bei Rezepten wo Eier
getrennt werden und fluffig
aufgeschlagenen immer ein Sieb zu
benutzen also immer die trockenen
Zutaten dadurch zu sieben warum Mehl
beim Biskuitteig nur kurz unterheben
weil man sich sonst die schönen
Luftbläschen von den Eiern kaputt macht
also so kurz wie notwendig bis die Mehl
Nester sich quasi aufgelöst haben weil
wenn ihr unnötig lange rührt sagt die
Masse immer mehr ein und dann habt ihr
nur noch so eine kleine Pumpe gemasse
statt eine große fluffige
beim Mehl unterrühren bleiben immer
mehlklümpchen im Teig
das liegt daran dass das Mehl
wahrscheinlich vorher nicht gesiebt
wurde also 7 ist wirklich immer sieben
auf Englisch ich weiß es gar nicht
auf jeden Fall immer sieht immer sieben
Leute weil es kann auch sein dass in
eurer Vorratsdose oder in eurem generell
in eurem mailpackung einfach auch schon
Klumpen sind wegen der Lagerung daher
777 warum muss man manchmal Mehl und
Flüssigkeit im Wechsel zugeben
okay das liegt daran dass wenn ihr die
trockenen Zutaten erst dazu gibt und
dann erst die Milch das ist bei
Muffinteig ganz oft zum Beispiel so dass
ihr dann erstmal die ganze kompakte
Masse habt dadurch dass so viel an
trockenen Zutaten hinzukommt die Masse
bald sich zusammen wird kompakt und dann
kommt Milch dazu dann müsst ihr euch
vorstellen dass sich das einfach gar
nicht das ist gar nicht mehr locker und
ihr kennt ihr das wenn sich Milch
einfach nicht mit einer Masse verrührt
und immer so eher umher schwimmt statt
in den Teig reingelangt genauso passiert
es dann und daher immer nach und nach
also immer abwechseln damit sich die
Masse gleichermaßen verbindet kann man
gefrorenes Obst direkt auf den Kuchen
rauslegen oder Auftauen vor dem Backen
als also wenn du es im Kuchen verbugst
in einen Teig kannst du gefrorenes immer
einfach drauflegen wenn du allerdings
das einfach nur als Deko auf eine
Sahnecreme gibst dann achte darauf dass
da nicht zu viel Flüssigkeit ist manche
haben ja auch diese Eiskristalle außen
das ist dann immer ein schlechtes indeed
weil wenn das auftaut hast du halt
Wasser auf deinem auf deiner Creme und
daher immer darauf achten dass das
vielleicht schon so halb angetaut ist
dass das Wasser schon mal weg ist beim
Backen warme oder kalte Eier am liebsten
immer warm ich wüsste kein Rezept wo
kalte Eier beim Backen gut sind also
immer gerne Zimmertemperatur man könnte
auch wenn man ganz kalte Eier aus dem
Kühlschrank hat könnte man die auch für
ein paar Minuten einfach in warmes
Wasser in so eine Schüssel legen wofür
kann ich alles weinsteinpulver verwenden
also Weinstein darf man nicht
verwechseln mit Weinstein Backpulver
weil Weibchen Backpulver gibt es ja
schon seit Jahren in den Supermärkten
Deutschlands aber Weinstein ist eher
noch so ein amerikanisches Ding da war
mir ganz wichtig dass ich Weinstein bei
uns im Online-Shop aufnehme und das kann
man so vielseitig einsetzen gerade beim
Backen es macht zum Beispiel Eiweiß
stabiler es verhindert dass
Kristallisieren von Zucker das heißt
wenn ihr zum Beispiel mal Kekse backt
dann kennt ihr das vielleicht wenn sich
der Zucker so kristallisiert und das so
unangenehm hart wird und wenn ihr dann
Weinstein verwendet im Rezept dann
verhindert ihr das ähm aber es macht
auch Muffins zum Beispiel fluffiger ihr
könnt auch wenn ihr zum Beispiel ein
Rezept ähm eineinhalb Teelöffel
Backpulver habt könnt ihr auch ein
Teelöffel Backpulver gegen einen halben
Teelöffel Weinstein ersetzen aber
abgesehen davon kann man Weinstein auch
bei Reinigungsarbeiten verwenden oder
wenn ihr Gemüse blanchiert wird euer
Gemüse einfach ja die Farbe wird
beibehalten gab im Brokkoli kennt man
das ja wenn man einfach noch Weinstein
hinzufügen also Weinstein da könnte ich
ein extra Video zumachen da kann man so
viel mitmachen im englischen wenn ihr
irgendwie amerikanische Rezepte habt
dann heißt weint schon immer cream of
Tartar und das darf man nicht
verwechseln mit baking soda weil bakings
oder ist das Natron was wir kennen und
cream of Tatar ist reiner Weinstein mein
red velvet cake von dir war leider nicht
fluffig ich habe aber Backpulver statt
Natron genommen lag es daran
ja also bei dem Rezept ist schon ganz
wichtig dass man das einhält dass man
auch Natron verwendet aber der red
velvet cake soll ja auch nicht fluffig
werden sondern eher das ist ja eher so
samtig so ein bisschen fatschi aber auch
nicht so luftig also man soll sich schon
darauf einstellen dass das Rezept dann
halt auch wirklich nicht luftig wird
aber wenn du es probiert hast müsste es
eigentlich so schmecken dass du sagst
boah richtig geil weil wie gesagt red
velvet ist einfach eine andere Liga aber
nicht fluffig definitiv nicht
[Musik]
warum zieht sich mein Hefeteig manchmal
beim Ausrollen wieder zusammen
das liegt daran dass der nicht lange
genug entspannen durfte dann müsstest du
ihm noch ein paar Minuten geben und wenn
ihr merkt der rollt sich aus ohne sich
zusammenzuziehen dann hatte er die
nötige Gehzeit Hefeteig ist fluffig und
geht auf Pizza danach aber Steinhart ja
das liegt daran dass es wahrscheinlich
zu lang gebacken wurde es könnte mehrere
Faktoren haben also wenn ich jetzt über
die Schulter schauen würde müsste ich
sofort vor der Fehler liegt aber
manchmal liegt es daran dass man denkt
okay die sieht noch nicht braun genug
aus ich lasse die jetzt noch mal zwei
Minuten aber eine Pizza müsste man
eigentlich am besten noch ein
vorgewärmten Pizzastein eigentlich bei
der maximalsten Temperatur die man hat
nur fünf sechs sieben Minuten backen
dann ist sie perfekt aber es gibt einige
Rezepte die sehen vor dass man die Pizza
dann 18 oder 20 Minuten backt dann kann
der Teig so fluffig sein wie man möchte
dann wird die Pizza einfach hart weil
die eigentlich nicht so lange Ofen sein
sollte kann ein Hefeteig zu lange gehen
oder ist das sogar gut wenn er sehr
stark nach Hefe riecht
also das ist eigentlich aber eine sehr
sehr penetrant nach Hilfe riecht ist es
ein Indiz dafür dass das schlecht
geworden ist man kann einen Hefeteig
lange gehen lassen sogar über Nacht
allerdings dann im Kühlschrank das nennt
man dann kalte Führung und dann
verhindert man einfach dass der durch
die wärmeeinflüsse schlecht wird und
wenn man den auf Zimmertemperatur gehen
lässt dann sollte man schon die Zeiten
einhalten und jetzt nicht drei vier fünf
Stunden lang den Hefeteig stehen lassen
und warum werden meine Portion nach dem
Backen hart und sind nicht schön weich
also Porter zumindest die nach meinem
Rezept die werden immer richtig richtig
fluffig wichtig ist dass man die auch
nicht aus dem Ofen nimmt wenn sie erst
richtig richtig goldbraun sind also sie
dürfen ganz leicht goldbraun sein aber
nicht zu dunkel dass man Indiz dafür
dass einfach zu lange drin waren und
anschließend mein Tipp eine große
Schüssel mit einem festen Deckel nehmen
und dann einfach da drin verschließen
und dann kann da auch nichts passieren
also immer dicht verschließen und nicht
so lange in der Luft lassen dann bleiben
sie auch schön fluffig
[Musik]
was machen wenn man einen schlechten
Ofen hat und der Kuchen in der Mitte
immer flüssig
also es kann ja sein dass du gar keinen
schlechten Ofen hast weil wenn der
Kuchen in der Mitte flüssig bleibt hast
ja da kommt irgendwie in die Mitte keine
Hitze oder du hast dieses Backblech was
natürlich was jeder zu Hause hat was
einfach beim Backofen mitgeliefert wird
das ist nämlich das ähm was unten so
eine Mulde hat das wird auch immer extra
gemacht weil sich das ja bei Hitze
wiederum verzieht damit er so ein
Ausgleich ist aber ich das erste was ich
gemacht habe als ich mein Ofen bekomme
und ich habe dieses Backblech beiseite
getan und habe dann mein ganz ganz ganz
Grades emailliertes Backblech oder das
Panda dazu ist ja auch das mit den
Löchern das gelochte das ist ja immer
gut für die Luftzirkulation wenn man da
einfach knusprige knusprigere Ergebnisse
möchte und dann habe ich es immer
vermieden dass in der Mitte da wo sonst
immer im Backblech halt diese Mulde ist
dass man Teig da auch gar wird und so
wird alles gleichmäßig klar das heißt
vielleicht hast du gar kein schlechten
Backofen sondern einfach nur das
schlechtere Blech da drin kann man auch
den Ofen nicht vorheiz vom Energie zu
sparen also und wenn ja was muss ich
dann beachten bzw wann muss ich
frühestens spätestens vorheizen
das geht bei Hefeteigen da kann man den
Hefeteig noch in den kalten Ofen tun und
den dann auf die Temperatur stellen da
muss man halt nur mal drauf achten dass
man so ein paar Minuten von der Backzeit
abzieht aber bei biscuitböden generell
bei so Tortenböden funktioniert das
nicht da braucht dein Biskuitboden quasi
schon diese Schockstarre dieses diese
Hitze damit es eben gleichmäßig was wird
also da kann man dann keine Energie
sparen aber man kann ja wenn man wenn du
weißt dass du irgendwie dann nachher
wieder was backst dann einfach die
Ofentür unbedingt geschlossen halten und
da so dann eben die Energie sparen fürs
nächste Rezept
warum reißt mein Käsekuchen von oben so
das passiert auch mir manchmal noch das
ist ganz normal man kann es halt
vermeiden es gibt halt verschiedene
Varianten entweder kann man den
Käsekuchen wenn er schon zu drei Viertel
gebacken ist einfach am Rand selber
anschneiden ein Zentimeter einfach mit
dem Messer damit man vorgibt wo der Reis
und am Rand sieht man es dann optisch
halt meistens nicht oder variante 2 ist
dass man die Ofentür einfach dass man
nach dem Backen ein Holzstab oder
irgendein Kochlöffel rein tut dass die
Luft so ein bisschen entweicht und man
nicht diesen diese Ofentür öffnet weil
durch diesen Temperaturunterschied kommt
eben dieser Riss zustande und dann den
Käsekuchen einfach die ganze Nacht oder
die nächsten Stunden im Backofen
auskühlen lässt so kann man es vermeiden
aber wie gesagt es ist auch bei mir ein
Phänomen manchmal achte ich auf alles
und trotzdem kommt der Riss rein warum
fallen Muffins sofort ein wenn man sie
aus dem Backofen nimmt
das kann zum einen an der Backform
liegen also Silikonbackform zum Beispiel
eignen sich meiner Meinung nach nicht so
gut zu Muffins backen wie diese
klassischen Waffeln Bleche und da kommt
natürlich auch wieder aufs Rezept an
also es kommt wirklich immer aufs Rezept
an das heißt es das Problem kann gar
nicht der Ofen sein oder das Muffinblech
sondern wirklich einfach die Rezeptur
und die Art und Weise wie dann der Teig
zusammengerührt wurde einfach nur mein
Rezept anschauen dann funktioniert das
auch
[Musik]
warum wurde mein Zahn Sebastian in der
Mitte nicht richtig fest
also der San Sebastian Cheesecake ist
einfach ein Phänomen für sich bei mir
gelingt er inzwischen immer auch wenn
ich mal einen anderen Ofen nehme ich
habe da einfach jetzt die Erfahrung drin
weil ich den auch gefühlt schon eine
Million mal gebacken habe aber wenn es
andere mir sagen der ist in der Mitte
noch zu flüssig liegt es definitiv immer
an dem Backofen das hier liegen was auch
gar nicht schlimm ist denn jeder
Backofen backt anders und wenn ihr fünf
Backofen habt wo ihr immer 200 Grad
einstellt garantiere ich euch jeder hat
eine andere Gradzahl in Wahrheit wenn
man dann Thermometer reinhalten würde um
die schwanken halt immer ein bisschen
und daher auch wenn es ärgerlich ist ihr
ihr könnt ja vorher nicht wissen ob der
innen flüssig ist Elastin halt diese
mindestens vier schon abkühlen dann
schneidet ihr ihn an und seht dass er
flüssig ist dann merkt ihr euch aber
fürs nächste Mal zwei oder drei Minuten
an Backzeit draufhauen also noch man
versucht starten und die Zeit einfach
mit dazu rechnen dann wisst ihr für
euren Backofen immer die richtige
Backzeit was kann ich anstatt
Philadelphia benutzen oder halt warum
muss es immer Philadelphia sein
Philadelphia ist eigentlich streng
genommen gar kein Frischkäse mehr
sondern eine Frischkäse Zubereitung und
verglichen mit anderen frischkäsesorten
schmeckt er halt sehr salzarm und ist in
der Konsistenz auch nicht so trocken das
heißt auch in der Verarbeitung nicht
daher könnt ihr euch sicher sein dass
mit Philadelphia deshalb Sebastian
Cheesecake am besten gelingt allerdings
könnt ihr euch auch mal durch andere
Marken probieren ihr werdet manchmal
merken dass bei bestimmten Marken der
Anschnitt ein bisschen trockener ist
also was ist trocken es ist halt einfach
nicht so dieses extrem
vanillepuddingartige smoose es schmeckt
einfach im Gaumen so minimal trockener
als wenn die Philadelphia verwendet aber
ich muss sagen vielleicht gibt es ja
auch irgendwo auf dem Markt noch eine
andere Sorte die ich noch nicht
ausprobiert habe und die mindestens
genauso gut ist und dann lasse ich mich
auch eines besseren belehren kann man
auch weniger Eier benutzen
also mein Rezept ist mit der eieranzahl
schon perfekt ich habe ja im Vorfeld
auch mal weniger genommen mal mehr und
ich habe euch ja extra die grammanzahl
dazu geschrieben das heißt je nachdem
wie groß das Ei ist braucht ihr da
vielleicht sogar auch eins weniger
beachtet immer auf die Gramm Anzahl weil
die Eier machen einfach den Kuchen
richtig schön cremig und weich
[Musik]
welchen Käse kann man für Mac and cheese
nehmen wenn man keinen Cheddar Käse mag
jeden fettigen also jeden sehr sehr
fettigen Käse fettarmer Käse
funktioniert nicht weil der sich nicht
gut auflöst also ihr könnt Gouda nehmen
oder Emmentaler das funktioniert
Parmesan funktioniert auch nicht Panade
hält nicht als ich Chicken Wings machen
wollte
es kommt drauf an was für eine Basis du
unten drunter hast also viele verquälen
ja einfach Eier das sollte aber ich weiß
woran es liegt nicht an den Eiern
drunter sondern weil die Panade zu grob
war die müsste dann einfach ein bisschen
feiner gemahlen werden oder einfach ein
paar mal drauf und mit dem Nudelholz und
dann hält die auch und Bam Bam bambraten
warum fällt die da manchmal versucht weg
beim Braten okay dann würde ich raten
doppelt zu panieren denn dann doppelt
panieren also nach der panierstraße das
gleiche noch mal und dann hält es auch
ein bisschen besser Soße die zu dünn
oder flüssig geworden ist wieder retten
also Soßen bei Gerichten kann man das
kann man andicken mit Speisestärke
entweder direkt rein sieben und rühren
oder die Speisestärke vorab in warmen
Wasser verrühren zum Beispiel zwei
Esslöffel Wasser und ein Teelöffel
Speisestärke vorab miteinander verrühren
und dann in die Masse gehen und nochmal
aufkochen mein Pro Tipp allerdings sind
Hefeflocken weil Hefeflocken machen ein
Gericht nicht nur würziger sondern auch
sämiger also einfach Hefeflocken rein
und dann habt ihr eine schöne sämige
Soße so wenn euch dieses Video gefallen
hat dann hinterlasst gerne ein
kostenloses Abo und dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten Video bis bald
tschüss
[Musik]